- I never want to do this again.
(music)
- [Voiceover] So this is
the Bits and Bobs Box.
Three fourth an inch turn in all around.
What does it mean when you
say to turn in all around?
- Okay, so this is way better
than if my kid had done this
so I'm feeling good about this right now.
- Here is the.
- I told you.
- Uh, I just poked myself.
What's an eighth of an
inch, this is disgusting.
I'm disgusting.
- I taped this too high.
- You totally did. (laughs)
- It's, it's okay, because
I have (bleeped) up wrap.
(blowing raspberries)
- After watching you I need to strategize
a little bit more.
- Is this vaguely at all
what I was supposed to do?
- Yes, that was exactly.
Do one on the other side.
(laughing)
- Is this a problem?
- I think I'm gonna die.
- No offense to you, this would be
you know, more fun with my kid
because I'm kind of bored
of it already. (laughing)
- You're not folding.
- So I need to fold?
- The right way.
- You need to fold.
- Did I mention I was crap at crafts?
- Can I take my bra off?
- Fold the flaps inward.
- Do we have to fold one more time?
- Oh, we made a box!
Oh my God.
- (bleeped) I tore it.
- Oh, I'm so hungry.
Are there any like
tacos, like spare tacos?
- I don't know where the hole is.
- That's what she said.
- [Woman] That's what she said.
(laughing)
- Where's my pen, this is a ribbon.
- What did you do?
- I'm making the hole.
- I'm (mumbling)
- I'm going to take the
scissors away from her.
- Oh man.
Uh.
I don't even want to put
in the effort anymore.
- Don't give up, told you,
it's the final countdown.
- It's sort of a box.
- Of bobs and bobbies.
Buts, what is it?
(laughing)
- [Woman] It's beautiful, it's beautiful.
- This is the most
perfect box I've ever seen
for your bits and (bleeped) bob.
- I got a little bored of it.
- [Woman] I made, oh, she gave up.
Let's be honest.
- I gave up.
- Okay.
- Put it together.
And what do we have?
Bits and bobs.
(laughing)
- I made a penis you guys.
- The box is going
straight into the trash.
- Pinterest is cool.
But a lot of the ideas
are not reasonable for
drunk people to try.
(laughing)
- [Woman] Do you need mouth to mouth?
- I need, I need pizza.